so stuart rhodes the head of the
right-wing militia group the oath
keepers made his first appearance
in court
in north texas today after being
arrested
yesterday on federal charges coming out
of washington d.c
he was charged with seditious conspiracy
and a couple of other counts tied to the
january 6 riots and insurrection at the
capitol last year he walked into the
courtroom shackled at the
wrists and ankles
wearing a pair of blue jeans heavy work
boots and a black carhartt t-shirt he
didn't say a whole lot in court but uh
he you know had the uh
charges against him read out he said he
understood them he's rich is actually a
yale law school graduate which his uh
lawyers noted after
the hearing um you know was very calm
and seemed fairly comfortable in court
it was a pretty short hearing i think
fewer than probably 10 minutes
and
really we heard very little from rhodes
i think the longest
sentence he said was just that i
understand in response to
the judge saying
asking whether he followed the charges
the federal prosecutors are seeking to
keep him
in custody ahead of his trial which will
ultimately
be in washington dc but he's going to be
held uh here in north texas
uh until thursday
when um
his lawyers will argue for him to be
released they said after the hearing
today that he plans to uh
fight the charges against him that he's
not a flight risk then he's not in
danger to the public